get ready to construct additional pylons
because an HD remaster of starcraft is
on the way be sure to subscribe for new
developments on this one but for now
here's what we know blizzard announced
that starcraft remastered will include
all the content from the base game and
the brood war expansion the graphics
have been boosted to quote 4k Ultra High
Definition and the audio is also getting
an upgrade if multiplayer is your jam
you'll be happy to hear that the
remaster is going to include matchmaking
as well as for connectivity to blizzards
online network the game's campaign will
feature new illustrations to enhance
storytelling as well as cloud saves for
campaign progress custom made maps
keybinds and replays Blizzard sierra
mike morhaime said with starcraft
remastered we're modernizing the
original game's visuals audio and online
support to ensure that players can enjoy
Starcraft for another 20 years and
beyond the publisher added that the
experience will feel identical to
veteran players Starcraft remastered is
in the works for pc and mac and is
slated to arrive this summer no info on
pricing just yet let me know in the
comments if you're keen for this one and
check back to gamespot for more newsy
things
[Music]